dans le reste de l'actualité un procès
aux assises s'est ouvert aujourd'hui au
tribunal de tours
un homme de 23 ans est jugé pour le viol
d'une octogénaire
les faits se sont déroulés en janvier
2018 à saint pierre des corps
à l'époque l'affairé avait suscité une
vive émotion dans le quartier
le procès doit durer deux jours flon
clavel était sur place
rarement une agression avait suscité une
telle indignation nous sommes en janvier
2018 quelques jours après les faits dans
le quartier dollar à batterie à
saint-pierre-des-corps 250 habitants se
rassemblent pour soutenir la victime et
crier leur colère
il faut dire que la faire juger depuis
aujourd'hui aux assises d'indre et loire
est particulièrement sordide le viol
d'une femme vulnérable le viol d'une
femme de 87 ans ce jour là la victime
rentre chez elle après avoir fait ses
courses quand sous prétexte de l'aider
un homme s'engouffre avec elle dans son
garage
c'est là que débute le cauchemar de la
victime son agresseur la tire dans le
salon lui enlève le pantalon et sa
culotte
il la pénètre avec ses doigts ensuite il
force sa victime à lui remettre quelques
dizaines d'euros
sa carte et son code près de trois ans
après l'accusé exprime sa honte mais
peine à expliquer son passage à l'acte
il concède avoir beaucoup bu et fumé du
cannabis la veille au soir
il est certain que l'addiction les
addictions que ce soit l'alcool ou les
stupéfiants ont joué un rôle dans le
passage à l'acte alors c'est une
explication c'est pas une excuse les
addictions lorsqu'on boit de l'alcool
c'est un élément volontaire mais ça peut
expliquer que certaines barrières qui
n'aurait pas dû tomber
et bien c b rock ces barrières sont
tombées en creux se dessine le portrait
d'un homme au parcours chaotique et
ballotté entre la france et l'algérie
entre le domicile respectif de ses
parents divorcés entre les foyers
enfin la prison 25 condamnations à son
actif
face à lui sur le banc des parties
civiles jeanine 90 ans absente une bonne
partie des débats à cause de son grand
âge elle a tout de même tenu à affronter
son agresseur sans rennes mais avec la
volonté de comprendre selon son avocat
ce qu'elle est venue chercher
aujourd'hui c'est essentiellement des
explications sur quelque chose qui lui
paraît incompréhensible c'est à dire
c'est ce pour quoi que si douloureux
pourquoi elle ce matin là alors c'était
une matinée pour elle comme les autres
elle partait faire ses courses
pourquoi ça ne s'est pas passé comme ça
pourquoi ce jeune garçon qu'elle ne
connaissait pas s'en est pris à elle de
manière aussi violente
et c'est vrai que c'est un point
d'interrogation qui appellerait une
réponse si on veut un peu d'apaisement
en état de récidive légale l'accusé
risque la prison à perpétuité
le jugement sera rendu demain soir à
l'issue de la deuxième et dernière
journée de procès